♪ (SENTIMENTAL PIANO MUSIC
PLAYS) ♪
Hi. It's me, Adrienne.
Somebody's agreed
to let me make a movie again.
That never fails to surprise me
and delight me.
She craved having
her voice heard,
and her vision being out there.
ELAINE LANGBAUM: From
when she was five years old,
when she was in kindergarten,
she always stood out.
It was always Adrienne.
It happened quickly.
In no time, she was the star
of this indie, cult film.
"I'm sitting in a diner,
freaked beyond belief.
What have we learned here?
Write it
and direct it yourself."
She really knew what she wanted.
She had such a clear idea of it.
You come in, you rush in.
Okay. I messed it up
a little bit.
ADRIENNE SHELLY:
It's fine. I don't care.
SPEAKER:
Her greatest joy was that child.
ANDY OSTROY: She was
the happiest I'd ever seen her.
I went to bed that night
the luckiest guy alive.
By the next night, I was living
the worst nightmare imaginable.
BRIAN:
My phone rings, and you said,
"Brian, get up here.
Adrienne's dead."
I just remember I fell to the
ground and I started screaming.
♪ (INTENSE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
ANDY: I get a call
from the detective, and he said,
"Andrew, we arrested the guy
who killed Adrienne."
Not a minute of every day
goes by
without me thinking of Adrienne,
and what my daughter,
Sophie, has lost.
What the world has lost.
This was gonna be her moment.
How are we here and she's not?
I just have a very specific
kind of satisfaction
when I see Waitress
on the Broadway marquee.
ADRIENNE: I was going for a tone
where you can find what's funny
in what's painful,
which has always kind of been
my strategy, anyway, in life.
ANDY: You're almost the same age
as her, here.
"Don't be afraid of dying.
Be afraid of never living."
♪ (SENTIMENTAL PIANO MUSIC
PLAYS) ♪